[Music]
[Applause]
Hi everybody. Uh yeah, my name is Jack.
I'm a researcher at Google and I'm the
tech lead of thinking within Gemini and
I'm going to give a brief deep dive into
thinking from the research perspective
uh within Gemini. So I'm going to kind
of give this talk in three stages. One
is to give a research motivation of why
we actually are excited about thinking
in terms of unblocking bottlenecks
towards intelligence. And I'm going to
give a kind of uh give a few examples of
how often discovering the most precient
bottlenecks uh in kind of our current uh
models uh our most advanced systems how
often if you can just identify the
crucial kind of uh issues and
shortcomings you often will then find a
solution and there's a reason how that
is linked to thinking and then going to
talk um a little bit more um just
pragmatically about what is thinking in
Gemini why is it interesting to
developers
And I think your someone is okay. The
slides are still not here.
We did do a rehearsal this morning where
the slides are there. But yeah, keynote
speaker SL. Yeah, someone's I can see
someone. Yeah, keynote speaker folder.
Jack Ray.
I think it's under keynote speaker.
Um anyway um it's going to come up soon.
You are close um person.
Um yeah but um and then I'm also going
to talk a little bit about what's next.
Ah I'm just sorry I'm just watching you.
There you go. Nice one.
Yeah that's great. Okay the slides will
appear. Thank you whoever is
coordinator. Apologies. I don't know
what happened. Um, and then I'm just
going to talk a bit about what's next.
So, Logan did a great job of kind of
giving an incredible overview of Gemini
as a whole ecosystem, everything that's
going on. Uh, I'm going to really be
focusing on on kind of what we're
excited about in the reasoning space.
So, with intelligence bottlenecks, uh,
we're kind of the message of this
section is really about uh, progress.
So, progress has really been marked by
identifying key bottlenecks towards
intelligence and then solving them. And
uh I'm going to kind of give some
examples throughout history. I'm going
to actually rewind the clock to 1948.
Claude Shannon, he invents the language
model, mathematical theory of
communication. He builds a language
model, a twogram, using a a textbook of
word statistics that was handculated and
he samples from it and he kind of
marvels at the samples. He feels like
these are these are getting pretty good.
They're a lot better than unogram
character this two gram word model. But
uh kind of he remarks like I think this
would be better if we could really like
make a better language model and scale
up this current method. So he really
wanted to just scale up the engram that
was the bottleneck like small amount of
data very you know elementary statistics
and and unfortunately for core Shannon
kind of the solution was pretty hard he
needed the digitalization of human
knowledge and he needed modern computing
to be able to aggregate these statistics
at scale. So you know that wasn't so
easy for him to solve. He had it a bit
more tricky. But fast forward a few
decades at Google uh in in the 2000s uh
my colleagues such as uh Jeff Dean are
training engram language models over
trillions of tokens. These are powering
at the time the most sophisticated
speech recognition and translation
systems uh and and a lot of progress has
been made. But their bottleneck was
actually uh with these systems was that
these engram language models were very
restricted to short context. and they
were because um there's an ex
exponential storage cost with uh context
length and there wasn't really a way
around that with with just sticking with
engrams. The solution was the early kind
of uh introduction of deep learning in
2010 uh with uh the introduction of
recurrent uh neural uh language models.
So recurrent neural networks apply to
modeling text where the recurrent neural
networks could avoid this problem by uh
storing compressed representation of the
pass into the state of a neural network
and they could now start to model beyond
a five gram sentences or even paragraphs
and this was a massive kind of uh step
change in improvement. However, a couple
of years later people would notice even
there there was a bottleneck. So uh the
recurrent neural network's
representation of the past is in a fixed
size state and this fixedsized state uh
uh there's only so much information you
could put into it and so as a result
there's often observed to be kind of
lossy a lossy kind of representation of
its context. The solution that was
derived I think once once people kind of
really encountered this this um
information bottleneck in the past was
actually just keep everything around in
terms of your past uh neural uh
embeddings and use an attention operator
to aggregate things on the fly. So this
was the birth of attention and then
shortly after transformers. So um
transformers then kind of led to the
modern deep learning revolution as we
know it and uh many other progress was
made. But if we skip forward 10 years,
we then are in 2024. We have uh large
language models. They're increasingly
powerful general conversational agents.
We have uh models such as Gemini chat
GBT. People are using them for all sorts
of use cases. And there that's where we
kind of come to the bottleneck that's
relevant to this talk, which is that
although these models are very very
powerful, they are still trained to
respond immediately to requests. So in
other words, in terms of a compute
bottleneck, there is a constant amount
of compute that they apply at test time
to transition from your request or your
question to the response or your answer.
So the bottleneck of test time compute,
this is relevant to thinking. Uh so we
can unpack this a little bit more. So
when we talk about a fixed amount of
test time compute, the test time compute
is interesting to you because that's the
compute that the model is spending on
your particular problem, your particular
question. And it and and and the way it
actually kind of mechanically works is
you have some text in your request. It
gets translated to tokens and then it's
going to go through a language model.
And at the transition from the request
to its response, it's going to pass some
computation up through a large language
model which will have some parallel
computation for every layer and it'll
have some iterative computation across
layers. So that computation is really
where the model can apply its
intelligence to your particular problem
and it's of fixed size. One solution if
you wanted a smarter model and more
computation is just to make the model
larger and then you can have more
compute and you can get a smarter
response. However, it's still not really
enough. Users might want to be able to
think a thousand or a million times and
have a very large dynamic range and a
lot of compute for very hard or
challenging or valuable tasks. And also
users might want to have a very dynamic
application of test time compute. So
less compute for simpler requests, more
compute for harder requests and have
this process be very dynamic and and and
instigated by the model. And that is
what motivates thinking.
So thinking in Gemini
mechanically, I'm sure almost everyone
in this room is familiar with this
general process where we will now have a
model and we insert a thinking stage uh
that the model can emit some additional
text before it decides to emit a final
answer.
So going back to this notion of test
time compute now we've added an
additional kind of loop uh of
computation where the model can kind of
iteratively uh loop and and perform
additional test time compute uh during
this thinking stage and this loop can be
potentially thousands or tens of
thousands of iterations which gives you
tens of thousands more uh compute before
it decides to commit to what its
response will be. And also because it's
a loop, it's dynamic. So the model can
learn how many iterations of this loop
to apply before it decides to actually
commit to its answer.
We train this model um to think to use
this kind of thinking stage via
reinforcement learning. So when we
pre-train Gemini, uh we then have after
a reinforcement learning stage where we
train it to do many different tasks and
we give it positive and negative rewards
depending on whether or not it solves
the uh solves the task correctly or not.
And this is essentially a very general
uh training recipe really. And it's kind
of remarkable it works that the model is
able to just get a very vague signal of
what is correct, what is not correct and
to back propagate this through this loop
of thinking stage such that it can try
and shape how it uses its thinking
computation and thinking tokens in order
to be more useful.
In fact, we weren't really sure this
would work. um it wasn't clear how much
structure we should put into something
like a reasoning stage and um although I
think probably many people here have now
seen reasoning traces and played with
these models I'll just show you a
historical artifact um from one of the
times we were trying to use
reinforcement learning we started to see
cool emergent behavior so in in this
problem there's kind of like an integer
prediction problem this was just like a
kind of a particular uh example uh in
this case kind of like um kind of like a
mathsy example and what we saw was the
model was using its thinking tokens to
actually first pose a hypothesis and
then test out the hypothesis and then it
found that basically things weren't
really working and and it kind of states
that this formula doesn't hold it
rejects its own idea and then it tries
an alternative approach and I think it's
easy to become desensitized to
technology because it's so amazing every
single day but we were truly blown away
when we saw the general recipe of
reinforcement learning was creating all
sorts of interesting emergent behavior
trying different ideas self-correction
And I think these days we see a lot of
different strategies that the model
learns to do. So it learns to break down
uh the problem into various components,
explore multiple solutions, draft
fragments of code and and and build
these up in a modular way, perform
intermediate calculations and use tools.
All under the umbrella of using more
test compute to give you a smarter
response.
Okay. So I've talked a bit about uh why
we are interested in thinking in terms
of the path to AGI and unblocking
bottlenecks of intelligence and just a
little bit about mechanically what it
is. Why is it interesting to developers?
Obviously the number one reason is we
think this is driving uh more capable
models and it also stacks on top of our
current paradigms of how we accelerate
model progress. So thinking uh we can uh
kind of accelerate this process by
scaling the amount of test time compute
and we find that this can stack as a
paradigm on top of pre-existing
paradigms such as pre-training where you
can scale the amount of pre-training
data and and model size and also post-
training where you can scale the quality
uh and diversity of human feedback for
many different types of tasks. And as a
result by within within Google by
investing in all of these and really
accelerating all of them uh we get kind
of a multiplicative effect. And why is
this interesting to developers? I think
it results in just overall faster model
improvement which is very nice.
We also see if we kind of uh look back
over uh our lineage of uh recent um
Gemini launches um you know there's
improved reasoning performance and and
we can actually map this to how much
test time compute these models will
devote to problems. So there's kind of
like a log scale test time compute on
the x-axis and performance across like
math code and some science topics. And
we see that there's kind of this trend
in increasing reasoning performance
whilst also it tracks very well with
increasing test time compute. And on the
far left uh you know you have 2.0 flash
experimental. This was a model that uh
was not launched with thinking back in
uh back in December last year. So
ancient history uh and now we have uh uh
on the left on the right hand side what
the the first uh launched version of 2.5
Pro.
So test time scaling is working
empirically.
Um but it's not just capability that
matters. It's also interesting from the
notion of being able to steer the models
uh quality uh over cost. So um you know
before uh you had the option of choosing
a discrete number of possible model
sizes and that was a way to gauge how
much quality you wanted and also how
much cost you wanted to spend um cost
you wanted to kind of incur for any
given task. But it was kind of a
discreet choice.
Now with thinking we can have a
continuous uh budget uh which allows you
to have a much more granular slider of
how much capability you want uh for any
given kind of class of tasks. And we
have thinking budgets now launched in uh
flash and pro uh in the 2.5 series. And
um this allows you to have very granular
choice of cost to performance and also
allows us to then push the frontier and
and and allow you to kind of augment and
drive cost higher and performance higher
if if your application requires it.
So okay, I think a lot of this stuff is
really covering uh ground that you know
uh up to the present day. So what what
what's next and what are we excited
about?
So, we're we're very excited about just
generally improving the models and
having better reasoning. Of course,
we're also excited about making the
thinking process as efficient as
possible. Really, we want thinking to
just work for you and be quite adaptive
and and be something that you don't have
to actively spend a lot of energy
tuning. And a big part of that is
ensuring our models uh are very
efficient in how they use their
thoughts. Uh this is definitely an area
of progress. I think we can find
examples of our models overthinking on
tasks and this is just an area of
research to get these things faster and
faster and and as cost-ffective as
possible. We're very proud of how
cost-ffective our Gemini models are and
this is just an area uh for improvement
as well. And there's also deeper
thinking which is really about scaling
the amount of inference compute further
to drive even higher capability.
So people may be familiar with Gemini
deep research where you can kind of uh
type in a query and then and then the
model will go away for a long period of
time and research a topic. We're also
now uh have announced at IO and we're
launching to trusted testers a notion of
deep think. Deep think is a very a very
high budget uh mode um thinking budget
mode built on top of 2.5 pro and its
desired application is for things where
uh you have a very hard problem and
you're happy to essentially um uh fire
off the query and then have some
asynchronous process that's running for
a while and you'll come back to to
arrive at a stronger solution. And its
key idea is uh we leverage much deeper
chains of thought uh and parallel uh
chains of thought that can integrate
with each other to produce better
responses. We find this uh enhances
model performance on very tough
multimodal code math problems. An
example would be USA math olympiad. This
is task that basically the
state-of-the-art model in January was
completely negligible performance. uh
2.5 Pro is now probably even better uh
with the the updated one today was about
a 50th percentile of all participants
that participated in math olympiad and
and with deep think it goes up to 6 65
uh percentile and the interesting thing
about deep think is as we continue to
both improve the base model and improve
the algorithmic ingredients that go into
deep think those two will stack together
as well.
Um, here is kind of like a just like a
video animation of of one of these USA
Math Olympiad algebra problems. And and
the key idea really with this video is
just this notion of having multiple
iterative uh ideas. So maybe the model
starts out with some proof by
contradiction idea, but then it explores
two different aspects, some rolls
theorem, Newton's inequalities. It
integrates them and eventually arrives
at some correct proof.
There's not that much you can take away
from this video, but it looks pretty
cool, so I added it. Yeah. Yeah.
One thing that's, you know, other than
we talked about math a little bit in the
previous slides, I'm very excited about
any application where the model can
spend longer and longer thinking on very
open-ended coding tasks and oneshot or
very few interaction vibe code, things
that would have taken us months uh in
the past. And and one example that I
like from a researcher is just um um
some of my colleagues kind of vibecoded
uh from from deep mind's original DQN
paper which was a a revolution in deep
reinforcement learning kind of vibe
coded uh Gemini vibe coded the the kind
of training setup the algorithm uh even
an Atari emulator such that it could
play some of the games and you know this
is uh remarkable to me because this
these kind of things would have taken me
and my colleagues uh months in the past
and these things are starting to happen
um uh kind of in minutes.
One thing I'm quite excited about
looking forward to the future is not
really the landscape of models but
coming back to like what's our gold
standard which is the human mind. I
would love for our models to be able to
contemplate from a very small set of
knowledge and think about it incredibly
deeply such that we can push the
frontier and one example I often think
about is Raman Jean who's a uh one of
the world's greatest mathematicians uh
from the early 20th century and famously
he he just had this one math textbook he
was kind of cut away from from the
mathematical community but he just from
a small set of problems he spent uh many
textbooks worth of thinking going
through problems inventing his own
theories to further extend ideas and he
invented a an incredible quantity of
mathematics really just by deeply deeply
thinking from a small source subset and
this is where I think we are going with
thinking. We want a model to be able to
be incredibly data efficient and
actually go to millions uh or or beyond
of of of inference tokens where the
model is really building up knowledge
and artifacts such that we can
eventually start to push the frontier of
human understanding.
So with that said, thank you very much
and uh